uh it's amazing when you meet a head of
state and you say what is your most
precious natural resource they will not
say children uh at first and then when
you say children they will pretty
quickly uh agree with you
but we're traveling today with the
minister of defense of colombia
um the head of the army and the head of
the police and we're dropping off 650
laptops today to children who have no
television no telephone and have been in
a community cut off from the rest of the
world for the past 40 years
the importance of delivering
laptops to this region is connecting
kids who have otherwise been unconnected
because of the farc the guerrillas that
started off 40 years ago as a political
movement and then became a drug movement
there are 1 billion children in the
world and 50 of them don't have
electricity at home or at school
and in some countries let me pick
afghanistan 75 of the little girls don't
go to school i don't mean that they drop
out of school in the third or fourth
grade they don't go so
in the three years
since i talked to ted and showed a
prototype it's gone from
an idea
to a real laptop
we have half a million laptops today in
the hands of children
we have about a quarter of a million in
transit to those and other children
and then
there are another quarter of a million
and more that are being ordered at this
moment so in rough numbers there are a
million laptops that's smaller than i
predicted i predicted three to ten
million but is still a very large number
in colombia we have about three thousand
laptops it's the minister of defense
with whom we're working not the minister
of education because it is seen as a
strategic defense issue in the sense of
liberating these zones that had
been completely closed off in which the
people who had been causing if you will
40 years worth of bombings and
kidnappings and assassinations lived and
suddenly
the kids have connected laptops they've
leapfrogged the change is absolutely
monumental because it's not just opening
it up but it's opening up to the rest of
the world so yes they're building roads
yes they're putting in telephone yes
they'll be television but the kids 6 to
12 years old are surfing the internet in
spanish and in local languages so the
children grow up with access to
information with a window into the rest
of the world before they were closed off
interestingly enough in other countries
it'll be the minister of finance who
sees it as an engine of economic growth
and that engine is going to
see the results in 20 years it's not
going to happen you know in one year but
it's an important
deeply economic and cultural change that
happens through children
31 countries in total are involved and
in the case of uruguay half the children
already have them and by the middle of
2009 every single child in uruguay will
have a laptop a little green laptop
now what are some of the results some of
the results
that go across every single country
include teachers saying they have never
loved teaching so much and reading
comprehension measured by third parties
not by us skyrockets
probably the most important thing we see
is children teaching parents
they own the laptops they take them home
and so when i met with three children
from the schools who had traveled all
day to come to bogota
one of the three children
brought her mother
and the reason she brought her mother is
that this six-year-old child
had been teaching her mother how to read
and write her mother had not gone to
primary school
and this is such an inversion and such a
wonderful example
of children being the agents of change
so now
in closing people say now why laptops
laptops are a luxury it's like giving
them ipods no
the reason you want laptops is that the
word is education not laptop this is an
education project not a laptop project
they need to learn learning and then
just think they can have let's say 100
books
and in a village you have a hundred
laptops each with a different set of
hundred books
and so that village suddenly has ten
thousand books you and i didn't have 10
000 books when we went to primary school
sometimes school is under a tree or in
many cases the teacher has only a fifth
grade education so you need a
collaborative model of learning not just
building more schools and training more
teachers which you have to do anyway
so we're once again doing give one get
one last year we ran a give one get one
program and it generated over a hundred
thousand laptops that we were then able
to give free
and by being a zero dollar laptop we can
go to countries that can't afford it at
all and that's what we did we went to
haiti we went to rwanda afghanistan
ethiopia mongolia places that are not
markets seeding it
with the principles of saturation
connectivity low wages etc
and then
we can actually roll out large numbers
so think of it this way think of it as
inoculating children against ignorance
and think of the laptop as a vaccine you
don't vaccinate a few children you
vaccinate all the children in an area
you